dead up doing her research obviously if
Islam didn't provide all of the proof
and the evidence that it was indeed the
truth from the Creator she probably
wouldn't have accepted she would have
stayed with what she was upon now what
would you say absolutely I think I think
the only thing that go to that it was
actually reading reading the Quran
reading the Quran yeah if you're no
Muslim and only if you just read the
Quran you see what it's about and this
is a friend of yours Sonny Williams
Sonny Bill Williams you know he came out
recently we had that tragic terrorist
attack that happened or keep this this
terrorist went into a house of worship
and gunned down 50 innocent human beings
including women and children New Zealand
that's not too far from Australia right
same culture same almost same people
they're more Scottish with more Irish
English but they're the same people same
culture same end of the world he said
the same thing you should get to know
Islam and you need to understand what
the stem is so it can give that give
that light which move what will get rid
of the bad